hi i'm lorne lanning creative director
at odd world inhabitants today i'm going
to take you on a brief tour of our
newest game
oddworld soul storm they've always known
you would come
do you know why you have in soul storm
you reprise the role of abe accidental
hero turned unlikely leader of an
emerging revolution
as you do battle through weird and
wonderful environments in an effort to
escape the all-powerful
and eternally greedy gluckens
we really wanted to bring this world to
life with what we call 2.9 d
platforming which adds much more depth
and immersion for the player
this sense of connection is also
reinforced through the use of the dual
senses haptic feedback
as you'll now be able to feel abe's
heartbeat in high alert and suspenseful
situations
there are well over 1 000 fellow
mudakins that you must try to save along
the way
but they are far more than helpless
workers looking to be saved
when used effectively you'll be able to
solve puzzles harness their combined
energy
and be given the tools they need to
fight alongside you
and there will be times when the extra
hands will be needed as you face off
against an array of heavily armed
enemies that will stop at nothing to
find
an end abe once and for all
in order to stand a chance against this
much larger threat
we gave abe the ability to scavenge loot
and pickpocket items from his
surroundings and use them to craft an
impressive
arsenal of his own that he can share
with others
you can also play as a non-lethal
pacifist or an agent of chaos
we wanted you to have the choice but
there is one iconic ability for our
shamanic protagonist
possession this mystical power allows
you to take control of your foes and use
their strengths and weapons against them
or use them to gain access to paths
still ahead
the odd world universe is a diverse
place and this means that there are some
environments and situations that require
a little more thought
patience and stealth you'll find dark
and dangerous caves heavily guarded
industrial sites and ancient forgotten
lands
here we've built lots of opportunities
for you to test your skills
and find different ways to handle things
it won't be easy if being hunted by an
army backed by a shady and wealthy
organization
isn't bad enough there are also more
dangers in the forms of natural
obstacles
ancient traps trials against swarming
dark creatures
and industrial hazards that must be
dodged crossed
and avoided ultimately abe's journey is
one of hope
freedom and truth there is a rich and
engaging narrative to discover
in a world full of lies and we've been
able to bring our characters to life
like
never before in true oddworld fashion
your actions in game will decide the
fate of abe and all those you manage to
liberate along the way
and we can't wait to see what you will
do
[Music]